meanwhile the big story yesterday the
cdc updating its indoor mass guidance
now recommending vaccinated americans
put the mass back on too
especially in areas with high
transmission and even advising
universal masking everybody in a school
needs to wear a mask even if they've had
the shot
here with reaction we've got fox news
medical contributor dr mark siegel we've
got a high school teacher out in
california
and author of the upcoming book hollowed
out jeremy adams
and new jersey mom of three nila hadley
good morning to all of you
good morning good morning neil neil
let's start with you because you're on
the front lines you got three
three kids going back to school in about
a month month and a half
when they heard they they're gonna have
to wear a mask
from sun up to sun down in the in the
school building
what did they say my son's
first reaction is he's not going back to
school
my daughters are not happy at all
it's something we're going to have to
discuss but my kids are
i don't want to say a mess but they're
pretty upset about it
what do you mean your son is not going
to go back to school
so last year he had a
secondary infection he had a reaction to
a mask which turned into a full-blown
skin infection on his face oh my
goodness
um he is left with a couple scars still
and um he
uh he he doesn't want to go through that
again i i don't blame him
all right it was a very painful
experience absolutely
uh jeremy you're out in california
you're in baker bakersfield california
uh they're saying that you know you're
gonna have to do it in california you
know governor
newsom is gonna say that but the whole
reason you
got the shot was so you wouldn't have to
wear the mask around the kids and now
you're gonna have to wear the mask
around the kids
jeremy it's absolutely frustrating i'll
be honest with you
uh the truth of the matter is you know
i'm not a doctor i'm not a scientist i
can't tell you if we're
we need to be doing this from a
scientific perspective but i can tell
you
that teaching in a mask is awful it's
ridiculously hard especially
if you're trying to you know use the
humanity of the classroom use humor use
your
facial expressions reach the kids and
these kids need to get back to a normal
situation
the last 16 months has not been good for
them and they they weren't doing
particularly great before you know which
is why i wrote the book hollowed out
so all the teachers i talked to
yesterday who got the vaccines because
we
know these kids needed to get back to
normal it's demoralized
absolutely and dr siegel you know
parents
are struggling to try to explain to
their kids okay this is what we're going
to have to do but you look at neil's
story she's got the son
who wound up with the the face infection
which is something a lot of people don't
think about because you're wearing it
all day
uh and and it takes its toll on your
face
and on your psyche that's right steve
there's big downsides to mass that have
to be factored in
and there's the idea of what kind of
mask are you wearing because if you're
wearing an n95 with a formal seal
that works really well but kids are not
going to tolerate that
and and so the idea is it should never
be a mandate it might be something i
you recommend if there's a lot of virus
but there isn't a lot of spread
in schools there isn't a lot of spread
among young children and you know star
reporter peter ducey
when she when he talked to jen zaki
yesterday
you got this feeling of a condescending
tone didn't you
we know and you don't we know and we're
going to tell you what to do so the
mistake the administration is making
is mixing masking with vaccines as you
know as
as the high school teacher just said i
mean you know
vaccines work masks shouldn't be
mentioned in the same sentence
yeah dr siegel so many people are
hesitant to take the vaccine
but joe biden said you get the vaccine
you can take down the mask
and now of course uh that turns out it's
not going to be the
suggestion going forward everybody's
gonna have to wear a mask regardless of
vaccination status
but also you know the fda has not given
final approval and there
are probably millions of americans who
said well i'm if the fda the federal
government
is not saying it's a hundred percent
safe with final approval i'm not going
to get it
so why is the government taking so long
this is an
all hands on deck situation
this is unprecedented and even though it
usually takes the fda
a long time in this case my opinion and
i think yours is they should get
off their duff and do it right now and
get it approved to send that vote of
confidence
because over 300 million doses have
already been given out it's not like
they don't have the data steve
they got the data they've got to move
fast and they got to license the vaccine
and then you're going to see a lot more
people taking it that are on the fence
yeah neela you know i remember when our
our kids were living in the house and
they were getting ready for school
right about now they'd start getting
excited about school you know
let's go get some new clothes and let's
go to staples and we'll get all the
spiral notebooks and stuff like this but
given the fact that now it sounds like
we're going to have to have the kids
wearing the masks again
that just made your job tougher getting
the kids out the door
absolutely it has i
i'm hoping he's going to be exempt
because of the severity of his
skin and how bad his face was
i mean like i said there's still some
scarring so
i am hoping that the doctors uh
recognize this and they agree with me
uh and then hopefully he'll be able to
go back to school
yeah like a normal kid uh as far as my
girls go
my older one's going into eighth grade
she said mom i don't want to be
homeschooled for eighth grade
yeah i don't blame her and then my sixth
grader this is this is
uh the social aspect of school is just
as important as the
education absolutely and jeremy you're
out in california
how much of an impact do you think the
teachers unions
had in convincing the government to say
everybody's got to wear a mask
well yeah i can't speak to the cta but i
can tell you most of the teachers that i
know
got vaccinated for a variety of reasons
but the number one reason is
as our parent just said a second ago
we've got to get back to a sense of
normalcy uh you know steve i'm
i'm a bit of a of a classroom romantic i
think that the the most certain door to
the american dream no matter what your
background is
is a high quality education which means
we need our teachers to be at their
absolute best
now the last year of learning for our
students has not been pretty you know
they've been behind
anonymous zoom calls sure sitting in bed
you know oftentimes texting as they uh
take classes
and we need to get back to a sense of
normalcy for sure we sure do and dr
siegel exit question this is only a
recommendation it's going to be up to
state and local leaders whether or not
your locality
actually says mask up everybody right
right and theoretically it's only
supposed to be in areas of a lot of
spread but kids spread more covet
outside school than in school and i
already told you they don't spread it
much in school
the danger is that it's going to be
extended to areas where there's not even
any virus around
yeah you're right there's a lot going on
uh dr
siegel teachers have to get vaccinated
absolutely
everybody who can get vaccinated should
dr siegel jeremy
neela thank you all for sharing your
stories today
thank you very much i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kilny and i'm ainsley earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews
and most compelling analysis